it was a New Year's Eve in 1961
and I was on a date to Las Vegas and we
were at the Sands Hotel nightclub and it
the lounge and there was dancing and my
date did not dance and but the other
gentleman another couple did so we were
up there doing the twist and unbeknownst
to me mr. Sidney was there was a bunch
of friends and he saw me that was New
Year's Eve and that may by the birdie
started and I heard through my agent
that he wanted to see me for the part of
Kim MacAfee and I I didn't wear any
those kind of clothes yet I found a
rust-colored pleated wool skirt that I
never wore and this shirt which I really
never wear blouses and and some rust
colored flats which I and I came in
there and mr. city says oh how long did
it take you to find those clothes so
much magic happened between mr. Sidney
and Margaret myself because the part of
you go Peabody in the Broadway show was
absolutely nothing I mean he never sang
he never danced he didn't do anything
and when we first you know got on to the
weather this set at Columbia and my
squib got bigger and bigger and bigger
every day you know I I thank my lucky
stars to be very friendly with and we've
been friends for God's many years and I
talk to em like every couple of weeks
three weeks a month and she calls me hi
mr. Ritter Ellie which is my real name
Robert Louis Ritter Ellie and I say how
you doin Kim you know or hi mrs. Peabody
over six months after and mr. Sydney had
this idea of me being on a treadmill and
they wrote Bye Bye Birdie for the front
and the back of the movie and it's
unbelievable when I think of it now it
was the treadmill
had no railings and it was up I don't
know how far the very far and then for
me to have fallen 22 feet didn't 72
unbelievable I wasn't scared in 62 no I
was just fine
mr. Sydney had such faith in his idea
and me that he paid for it himself
because Columbia did not want to do it
and then on opening night when when well
before then when Columbia saw it they
reimbursed him I remember going to the
premiere with mother and daddy in 63 at
Radio City Music Hall we had been there
mother daddy and I when when mother and
I came to America when I was six years
old and of course we didn't speak
English and sitting there when I was 6
years old and was so huge and you know I
came from a village that was I was there
two years ago under a hundred people the
seats you know was so beautiful and this
huge huge screen but I did understand
the dancing of the Rockettes and
everything and then to have the opening
of I pretty my goodness
you